welcome back to New rockstars I'm Eric
Boss and this is a breakdown of all the
Easter eggs cameos and details you
missed in the flash the 2023 film
directed by Eddie muschietti and
starring Ezra Miller and Michael Keaton
in this Bonkers lineup of surprise faces
from the DC Multiverse further running
before I continue this movie does a lot
of things pretty well and I want to take
you through it scene by scene for just
some interesting points that are easy to
overlook also pretty support our Network
by subscribing to this channel subscribe
to the Deep dive channel for our
Spielberg summer slate and to the break
room for our instant reactions to all
this great stuff and please support us
with something from nerdright.shop like
this Smiles Maryland Smokey Birds dive
shirt or an indie I love you shirt okay
the film opens with the hands of a clock
spinning into place precisely at 902
representing the way Barry can speed up
and slow down time in this movie yeah in
this opening scene poor guy remains
trapped on the timeline of a barista
moving way too slow played by a very
funny British comedian Kieran Hodgson
now this place is called bilby's Cafe
which is a nod to the argumentative
psychologist dinner guest in H.G Wells
the time machine which is one of the
earliest works of fiction to explore the
very concept of time travel very
specifically in need of carbs as fuel
tying into his constant hunger from
Justice League Barry orders APD HRC on a
roll which is like peanut butter honey
raisin and cheese which his anxiety
forces him to see every every
incremental step of building and Alfred
calls and Barry asks if he could just
call Diana or someone else or Superman
and Barry see Superman on ATV news
report using his heat vision to help a
volcano erupting in Guatemala presumably
this is Henry Cavill Superman though we
don't see him in close-up Barry quick
changes into a suit and he runs outside
to strike the Speedster pose despite
being low on fuel
is by a group of fans
sounds good but are you actively eating
that candy bar
maybe you could throw it to me I need
you here now hi Bruce yes I'm now in
other instance is when people hurl stuff
at Barry's head he's able to slow down
time and quickly sidestep it remember
when benap like Batman threw the
batarang at his face in Justice League
and this movie actually calls that back
later with Michael Keaton Batman
throwing a frying pan at the berries
heads in the kitchen later but here
because Barry's low on energy the candy
bar just thinks into his head now this
suit is a new one from the last time we
saw him like when Barry lowers his
goggle eyepieces you can actually see
some light up text inside showing he has
a new heads up display which logically
must be fast enough at buffering to keep
up with his super speed all this was
supplied to him by his good friend and
he later calls his best friend Bruce
Wayne so as Barry Zips from Central City
all the way to Gotham City he passes all
kinds of drain these are not right next
to each other and he Zips past the
gotham sign showing his population over
10 million a lot of people live in here
Batman drops out of his aircraft on this
motorcycle it looks so great Ben Affleck
now Don's a gray and blue suit a classic
color scheme that Batman has worn in
past comics and not colors that we
normally see Batman wear in live action
this is really cool to see now the
reason Bruce needs Barry's help is
because there's been a robbery gone
wrong and the robbers are using chemical
weapons one must imagine they were
acquired from ace chemicals because
that's where like all the chemicals come
from but the credits confirmed that this
group of criminals are the Falcons well
known Gotham City crime family and one
detail you might have noticed steers
that the Falcons fire upon Batman on his
motorcycle first and only then does
Bruce returned the fire seems like the
sequence was designed to be very mindful
of collateral damage Bruce lays out a
spike strip ahead of kids offloading the
school bus but the armored truck swerves
and then Bruce has to follow them on a
bike and meanwhile Barry heads to the
hospital this is Gotham General Hospital
and on the wall we see this is the
Martha Wayne Institute suggesting Bruce
paid for this Wing in honor of his
mother Martha Barry has to run inside a
lower level of the building trying to
untangle the utility line hoses a visual
metaphor for the complexities he will
deal with in this movie Tangled
timelines and knots that this cannot be
untied newborn babies get endangered and
I swear to God what a terror to watch
these aliens free fall but Barry's able
to save them but as he mentions later he
can't just grab them because you know
that would force them to puke would
really do damage to their digestive
tracts we used to gingerly catch all
these little buddies and various
containers like a freaking microwave but
also as a service dog he rescues tries
to take a bite of that burrito he warms
up to constantly Karma load and
overcharge here it's kind of a running
joke in this movie that Barry always
denies others from taking a bite of the
snack food including cameos by director
Annie muskete who's later is the guy to
take a bite the hot dog now there is an
amazing long take where Bruce skids
along the pavement his toe cable
severing the top off a taxi he's able to
grab the guy they almost dropped the
chemical
Diana arrives using the last of Truth to
grab all of them leading some amazing
truth telling including Barry making
some confessions about his sexual
history go back home Barry calls his dad
Henry now played by Ron Livingston
recasting Billy crudup and Justice
League due to some scheduling conflicts
their appeal trial is going to be the
next day and during this call Barry
disassociates and returns to the memory
of their Old Neighborhood House and
Barry recalls the day Nora was killed
and how they dance to this specific song
that comes back throughout the movie
youngberry wears a Scooby-Doo shirt
gotta get in that Warner IP but
youngberry complains about his math
assignment which apparently is to come
up with as many possible equations that
could equal 24. which he's right it is
ridiculous because there is an infinite
amount of ways you can get to 24. but
another foreshadowing of his multiversal
dilemma and how infinite Journeys can
lead to that same endpoint the same
24-hour day that you can never change
now the reason Nora is left alone is
that Henry has to go back to the store
to get a can of tomatoes for the
spaghetti sauce that she makes and
because he never looked up when he got
that can in the direction of the
security camera he doesn't have a valid
Alibi for the appeal later this movie
oddly comes down to Spaghetti as
metaphor for everything specifically the
Multiverse Michael Keaton Bruce Wayne
uses uncooked spaghetti noodles to
demonstrate this movie's alternate take
on Multiverse logic and of course
spaghetti the recurring fuel for Barry
and his younger self as they constellate
their carbo load and the meal that his
mother made that the house just smelled
like but interestingly we never get a
real answer as to who killed Nora Allen
just said I guess there were robbers who
were supposedly casing the house and
waited for Henry to leave had thought no
one would be there and ended up stabbing
her now in the comics Nora Allen is
actually killed by reverse flash uobart
Bond who plays a much bigger role in the
flashpoint Comics as it's based on
though structurally Barry's younger self
I guess you could say it plays a similar
role as guard Clash it might be why he's
often dressed in yellow in this movie
reverse flashes colors Barry now
accesses the realm beyond the speed of
light that he later calls the Chrono
Bowl it's this movie's visualization of
the Multiverse working similarly to the
Tesseract and Christopher Nolan's
Interstellar it's really an array of
moments shown across a Time stream it's
interesting how it's kind of an
Amphitheater or a Coliseum in an arena
with Barry right in the middle of it as
if he is the epicenter of the earthquake
that ruptured the Multiverse here so
Barry tells Bruce Wayne about his
ability to do this and Bruce humors him
but he warns him about the dangers of
destroying everything saying that even
if it would mean leaving their parents
dead those scars make us who we are
remember this Bruce Wayne already knows
that Barry will be time traveling at
some point in his life because he saw
Barry appearing through Rift in time and
Batman v Superman I like how in the
background behind Bruce is this Barber
Shop Grayson's a nod of course to Dick
Grayson Robin also across the street is
wiz Comics which could be a nod to the
Wiz Comics label that Captain Marvel
shazam appeared under Barry rushes to
tidy up his apartment before Iris walks
in and I just love the timing of all
that rubbish dumping out of his closet
it looks like a practical time gag by
Andy muschietti which includes this
Jack-in-the-Box that rolls out and
perfectly pops up I believe that could
be a red balloon on the side of it and
that clown reminded me of Pennywise and
not too musketes work in the it films
also in Barry's apartment is a poster of
Raquel Welch from 1966's one Million
Years BC on the wall that Barry vibrates
rapidly to phase through and not at the
star sink Redemption when Andy the
frayne uses the same poster to cover him
tunneling through his prison cell wall
Stephen King oddly over praise this
movie on Twitter and I honestly think it
could just be because this nod to the
all-time best cinematic adaptation of
his work that being his Novella Rita
Hayworth in the Shawshank Redemption vs
Rita Hayworth was the first
pulled over the hole and yes I am
including The Shining because Stephen
King hated Kubrick's adaptation despite
it being one of the best films of all
time also I think Stephen King just
likes any Miss Kitty because Miss
Kitty's it films brought king a butt ton
of money in royalties honestly I think
it's chapter 1 and chapter 2 might be
the most profitable Stephen King film
adaptation Barry returns to the Chrono
bowl and rewinds time past the events of
Justice League we see forms of shirtless
Henry Cavill Superman Aquaman Wonder
Woman the moment backflip through the
batarang at his face his dad Henry on
the other side of the prison visitation
window sadly I couldn't see any Ray fish
or cyborg you know Warner I'm pretty
sure he was there too now yes the bfx of
the people in the Chrono Bowl doesn't
look that good Andy muschetti said that
this was meant to be seen from Barry's
point of view distorted with light and
with texture a kind of Water World which
I suppose is meant to mean that all this
is a representative dollhouse of the
moments in reality he could revisit but
these are just tableaus of reality not
really meant to be seen as reality
itself if so I just don't know if they
leaned enough into that artificiality
for viewers to get that but there is
some really great coloring in this movie
like notice is when Barry initially
Alters history to put that can of
tomatoes in Nora's card his speed force
is warm and golden because in his new
suit that's just what color the speed
force is colored despite normally
appearing blue and past iterations we've
seen him in but later when he left his
mom go when he's not wearing that suit
the color is cold in blue which matches
the coloring and Barry's memory of his
mom's bed when his mom was alive and
dancing with him that day the kitchen
and his shirt are yellow but when he
remembers her death the room and his
shirt have switched to Blue and now when
Barry returns to the Chrono Bowl we see
his altered life with Nora alive
birthdays Barry learning to shave
because Henry has not been incarcerated
now and it's this moment that dark flash
bumps him knocking him to 10 years prior
you think about it he's really
fulfilling his own destiny and closing
his Loop the time travel logic of this
movie overall is the predestination
closed loop style of time travel in
which events happen because they've
always happened as young Barry crosses
the street he kicks over two receptacle
cans for house number 13 foreshadowing
how he will become dark flash by
knocking two berries out of sync in a
very unlucky position for both of them
in young berries bedroom there are
posters for other Warner titles Pacific
Rim and Inception and on the door be for
Vendetta when old Berry speeds around
the room to pack him in couch cushions
he sees how young Barry has pinned
Nora's gift of that stuffed monkey to
the dartboard and notice after we return
to normal speed it is no longer on the
dartboard so all very worried that this
Salter timeline would result in
youngberry and therefore he thinks
himself would no longer have his powers
he takes young Barry to the research lab
to recreate the conditions of his
power's origin Lightning goes through
the older to the younger and knocks out
one of his teeth into youngberry's mouth
I guess this tooth representing the
transition of power this movie really
uses youngberry's early discovery of his
powers to give us the movie that a flash
origin movie would have been had Barry
Allen not had to have been backdoored in
Batman v Superman and in Justice League
and we really see how older Barry
mentoring a younger Berry results in
diminishing returns intellectually a
copy of a copy not unlike Michael
Keaton's film multiplicity and I feel
like all the sloppy spaghetti in this
movie Barry's nickname of monkey was at
least tangentially in The Ether from
this movie did you bring me a monkey so
Zod arrives with the same creepy
broadcast as we saw in the 2013 Man of
Steel film oldbury recalls how he did
try to help during that battle of
metropolis when the world engine began
to terraform the city and we see his
goofy DIY suit and he saves just one kid
really just by turning him away from
seeing his dad die recalling that whole
idea of save just one person from
Justice League and now during the Battle
of metropolis Bruce Wayne also comforted
a kid in Batman v Superman by turning
her away from her dead parents in nearby
Rubble well Barry looked at the members
of the Justice League Victor Stone just
to see he's still playing football as
number 82 for the Gotham City University
team Victor Stone also turned away from
us in that photo Diana in on the map and
he looks up Arthur Curry finding his
father Thomas Curry Lighthouse Keeper
everyone's favorite live-action Clone
Trooper Tamar Morrison making a cameo
Barry asks if his wife is the queen of
Atlantis and Thomas looks back to see
his wife who isn't Nicole Kidman but
does look like she's about to say
heartbreak feels good in a place like
Maine they talk about how in this
timeline Eric Stoltz is Marty McFly and
Back to the Future it's a reference to
how before Michael J fox played the role
Eric Stoltz was cast and they shot huge
portions of that movie before recasting
Marty with Michael J fox in this time
later Stoltz was never recast and young
Berry's roommate has a tattoo of Stoltz
on his inner thigh and it's interesting
to note that at one point Back to the
Future director Robert zemekis was
attached to direct this movie as with
Back to the Future especially Back to
the Future Part Two he really perfected
all the blocking of the effects of
doubling up an actor with a body double
to share a scene with himself which he
had to be definitely built on in this
movie now we don't know if it's just the
roommate's confusion or this being an
alternate timeline but they do say that
Michael J fox is in Footloose which
would be plausible because he was a big
sitcom star in the 80s but then they say
Kevin Bacon was in Top Gun which is also
plausible because he would have been a
big star in the 80s and then they talk
about the volleyball the gay guys in the
planes which might be why Tom Cruise
over praised this movie when he saw it
but his roommate does get one reperd
saying hi Batman quoting the Michael
Keaton version of Batman and I guess
that would have become a kind of
Catchphrase that he would have said a
lot over the years now let's talk about
something that we never knew we needed
but now can never get enough of Magic
the gathering's upcoming universe is
beyond set the Lord of the Rings Tales
of Middle Earth the Lord of the Rings
Tales of Middle Earth is an absolute
epic introduction of your favorite
characters stories and settings from the
genre defining fantasy novels directly
into magic the gathering's trading card
game whether you love the Lord of the
Rings or you're an OG magic player Tales
of Middle Earth is the perfect set to
learn to play magic with your friends or
get back into magic with your favorite
Middle Earth characters not only will
you feel like you own incredibly
stunning art pieces from The Lord of the
Rings but these are mechanically unique
cards that allow you to play out scenes
that would never happen in the book it
could totally happen in the game Tom
bobadillo versus Gandalf who's got the
better singing voice I feel like I'm
fighting for the fate of Middle Earth
with the wildest game strategy I could
imagine the best way to join the
fellowship is to grab a friend and start
your adventure you can pre-order now the
Lord of the Rings Tales of Middle Earth
on Amazon with the link below play
digitally on MTG Arena on June 20th or
pick up your starter kit and more packs
at your local game store starting June
23rd onto Wayne Manor which is now the
burglary house in Stanford Lincolnshire
England relocated from the net worth
house in the 1989 Batman film now that
Mansion exterior was actually changed to
a matte painting in 92's Batman Returns
but I think this could just be another
detail pointing to this being not quite
Earth 89 from the 80s and 90s movies
inside Bruce does have a similar room
with a collection of armor and weaponry
as we saw in the 89 film but in this
film the room has exterior windows with
light pouring in as opposed to it being
just an inner room of the mansion in the
kitchen Michael Keaton Bruce Wayne
crawls out of a cupboard a creepy
background detail that feels like much
Yeti playing homage to his shots of
Pennywise and it our writer Gina pointed
out and I very much agree that Keaton's
Bruce in this movie is at least a subtle
homage to the dude in The Big Lebowski
flip-flops a cardigan the long hair and
that perhaps all this movie's references
are messages to Barry for things he
needs to do like the Dude abides and
Barry just needs to just abide and not
try to change his fate which is also the
lesson Marty McFly learns at theater
Back to the Future Part three not the
first Back to the Future Marty
absolutely changes his fate and the
whole thing is really a hilarious
reflection on the commercial
aspirationalism of the 1980s and I love
it Bruce plays the frying pan and
youngberry Dodges it slow motion just
like Barry did with the batarang and
Justice League but oldbury just gets
whacked with everything this is all set
to Chicago's twenty five or six to four
which is a reference to a time of day
early in the morning when this song was
written just another reference to time
in this movie Bruce uses uncooked
spaghetti noodles to explain the
ultimate Multiverse logic of this movie
as opposed to Avengers end game which
dealt with Branch timelines this movie
poses that rupture to the timeline at
these fulcrum points you end up on
Alternate life paths that had already
been unfolding differently thus why Eric
Stoltz in the past in the 1980s of this
reality was Marty McFly a little detail
while Barry's mother Nora used canned
tomatoes and freshly made pasta Bruce
uses store-bought dry pasta and a huge
freaking brick of fresh parmesan which
would have been more expensive but he is
a billionaire in an eccentric the
berries enter the bat cave and Danny
elfin's music is swelling we revisit the
sweeping Art Deco designs of the cave
interior just these impractical Cliffs
of the Batmobile as well as the lovely
old school computer interface with
Keaton's bat computer with its
rollerball scrolling Mouse after
uncovering the Batmobile youngberry
finds a bag that laughs
I
and neither the silk bag that Jim Gordon
found on Jack Nicholson's Joker's dead
body at the end of the 89 film
and I explained in my deep dive of that
movie that a later comic revealed that
it was a lapping box inside of the silk
bag but in my head Cannon it was a bomb
that joker planned to use to scar Harvey
Dent's face Billy D Williams and the
press conference that he knew would
announce this Joker's defeat in the
final scene of that movie the pan that
Barry uses is inscribed with a message
from this versus Alfred presumably the
one played by the late Michael goth
Bruce touches a photo of himself with
his parents we'll see that his fingers
are bruised showing that he still might
be doing some crime fighting or at least
training he scans his eye to open this
bat suit room from the left there is the
year one bat suit with gun holsters oh
then a bat suit with a blue cow showing
that we had a similar design taste his
Bat leg straight from the left is the
1989 bat suit you can tell from the
ultimate chest emblem then to the right
of that the 1992 Batman return suit with
the updated emblem in the cape class
pulled back a bit then a scuba bat suit
and then a desert terrain bat suit with
goggles in the middle is his current bat
suit which really merges the best of the
design elements of these including
angular eyebrows on the cowl to match
Keaton's natural eyebrow shape which I
explained in my breakdown is really just
to make his mask more of a theatrical
reflection of the damaged Soul
underneath Barry wakes up to find a
mostly redacted document reported on the
arrival of a kryptonia to Earth
including you mentioned of a metallic
Crystal which might be the same crystal
chunks that impale young Barry to
disfigure him into dark flash later the
Batwing lowers like an actual bat
hanging from the slack tights and Batman
says the line yeah
I'm Batman over his head half the lights
are burnt out showing how little he's
really kept up this bat cave or at least
no longer has an Alfred to help him with
it later when he calls back his other
big line from the 1989 film you want to
get nuts
let's get nuts the Ring of lights over
his head is all illuminated making the
image of an Angelic Halo perhaps a sign
that this Bruce is destined to die at
the end of this path in this timeline
they take the Batwing to Siberia and
Batman ejects as elfman's theme just
starts pumping and the Batwing is framed
in the light of the Moon a visual call
back to Tim Burton's shot in the 1989
film that recreated the bat signal it's
so great they find the Kryptonian
chamber and youngberry says that's where
you keep Superman in a big scrotum which
is kind of ironic given kalel's Escape
pie that left Krypton and Man of Steel
was designed to look like a sperm cell
to reflect kalel's possession of the
full Kryptonian genetic codex which we
learned this movie Cara has inside they
find an emaciated kerazorl's cousin
weakened from the lack of access to
Earth's sun she wears this drab prison
clothing with Russian lettering that
translates to the most dangerous they
escape the guards and they make it to
this lift where Batman extends measuring
tape from his crotch region it kind of
looks like seven inches nice he asks the
berries how much they weigh which is a
call back to when he asked Vicki Vale
her weight before sending her with the
grappling hook in the 89 film outside
there is a solid two minute long take
first we see Cara's hand in the sunlight
gaining strength and then her Ascent
happens off screen so that when Batman
lowers his fist she is framed directly
behind it she takes out the other guards
and she Zips back to block a bullet that
was headed directly for Bruce's mouth
back in the Mansion as they watched the
news reports about Zod there's actually
a ticker at the bottom of the newscast
reading there are most Pharmaceuticals
declares bankruptcy so in this universe
it's their remotes instead of theranos
which also just sounds like thermos I
love it Kara regains her powers in the
sunlight she flies off Bruce devises a
bat kite to harness lightning to restore
old Barry's Powers it doesn't work so
Kara flies him up to finish the job
youngberry takes the 1992 batsuit to
engineer this new flexible DIY flash
suit sawing off the cow's ears to make
it more aerodynamic but the fact that
this Berry was in a bat suit might have
led to his dark flash looking more
nightmarish because Bruce designed these
to look like monstrous gargoyles and
strike fear in the hearts of others case
in point olberry has a nightmare jump
scare of dark flash who snarls at the
camera and sits much Yeti as a horror
director doing a superhero movie now it
kind of feels like Sam raimi's random
Green Goblin jump scare in Spider-Man
2002 Cara returns do you know what the
symbol stands for
Supergirl means hope right a call back
to Man of Steel when we learn the house
of el sigil translates to Hope and when
they jet over to the desert youngberry
try tries to turn his head in that 92
cow just a runny joke of the old bat
suit designs making it impossible to
turn your head in addition to Michael
Shannon returning a zot in this movie
Angie Trey returns as feyora his
Kryptonian second in command from the
2013 movie early in the battle young
Barry gets slashed across the face with
that Kryptonian Weaponry this first
instance of his disfigurement Zod
reveals to Kara that they intercepted
kalel's pot and the infant did not
survive so from there forward Cara is
just dead set on killing Zod actually
the berries wanted to avert her fate
they really should have intercepted
earlier to keep her from learning that
despite their progress in this battle it
ends with Batman Kamikaze and the
Batwing and designed ship shield and
Cara getting stabbed by Zod for trying
to stop the world engine so the berries
re-enter the Chrono Bowl to try to fix
this and when they return I like that
they loop back precisely on the moment
their past selves went boot to boot and
dunked on all those kryptonians meaning
that they were preoccupied with this
low-hanging fruit and they wouldn't have
gotten in the way of themselves but now
Batman gets hit by the big Kryptonian
and he tries to eject with the Batwing
but he's just sustained too many
injuries and Kara doesn't make it either
this time when Bruce dies Barry says we
couldn't bring you back could we and
Bruce says you already did and then he
looks up his body going still and
lifeless perhaps he's looking into the
beyond all the Spheres of the other
Universe soon also being brought back
young Barry gets his arm impaled with
krytonian metal shards and his body just
heals around it allowing him to
weaponize these in the Savage way he
lives back again and again and again his
body growing more disfigured until the
Chrono Bowl just ruptured and dark flash
appears who we learn is a young Berry
aged countless years into the future
after countless failures to fix things
remember earlier Barry said that some
individuals and timelines were attracted
to each other through Destiny like
magnets and now it appears like a
different universe is magnetized to each
other we counted five different
protobules colliding here the first is a
black and white one showing George
Reeves Superman from the 50s TV series
Adventures of Superman his stands are
actually filled with the black-headed
robot from season 1 episode 17 The
Runaway robot at the center of that
critical is an alternate flash running
into place Jay Garrick played by Teddy
Sears from the CW Flash series when he
played Jay Garrick from her three and
you see he's wearing the Crimson Comet
old school helmet George Reeves was
actually later are portrayed by Ben
Affleck in the 2006 film hollywoodland
which has one of the most anxiety-filled
moments I think I've seen in any movie
an incident that George Reeves actually
experienced can I shoot you
why would you want to do something like
that so the ball bounces off can I if
you did shoot me and the bullet bounced
off it might accidentally hit someone
else then this blue Universe spear with
the late Christopher Reeve Superman
recreated with CGI and I decided
Supergirl from the 1984 film played by
Helen Slater I think this would be less
controversial to recreate Christopher
Reeve like this if they just use archive
footage of Reeve instead of puppeting
him to make new gestures and expressions
but alas then this gold sphere showing
the late Adam West Batman and I think
behind him you can see his retro 60s
Batmobile and then this green sphere
with Nicolas Cage Superman long-haired
the same suit that he tried on in the
famous 90s Tim Burton wardrobe test for
Superman lives and here he's fighting a
giant spider this came from Kevin
Smith's story when he was hired to write
a version of the script and producer
John Peters had some bizarre demands for
him on how he wanted Kevin to write the
Superman character he's gone three
things okay I said all right
one I don't want to see him in that suit
two I don't want to see him fly
and three he's gotta fight a giant
spider in the third act I like
strips kind of like
cinematic history so youngberry
sacrifices himself to erase dark Flash
from existence and the Multiverse all
recedes and Barry returns to the
supermarket to put the canned tomatoes
back but on a high enough show so that
Henry Allen's face would show up on that
security camera and he'd be exonerated
so Barry says goodbye to Nora by saying
the full I love you more I love you
first phrase this Speedster finally able
to beat his mom to the punch here
outside the courthouse the camera guy
whose hot dog gets stolen is a cameo by
director Andy machete and Barry despite
thinking hiru has returned to a restored
fixed universe that Bruce Wayne of this
universe is George Clooney last scene in
1997's Batman and Robin this doesn't
mean Barry is in that movie's Universe
because that was technically Earth 89
which has some crazy Joel Schumacher
production design that this universe
doesn't seem to have he's just in a side
Universe where Bruce just happens to be
George Clooney and Aquaman just happens
to be Jason Momoa as we learn in this
movie's post-credits scene it ends with
Barry's tooth falling out but you know
it's probably gonna fall out anyway from
all that junk food the guy has to starve
down to stay energized let me know your
thoughts on this movie and remember to
subscribe to our new channel the Deep
dive And subscribe to the break room and
support by grabbing some merch at
nerdright.shop you can follow me on
Instagram and Twitter eavos following
the rockstars And subscribe to new
rockstars for more announcements
everything you love thanks for watching
bye
[Music]